arrivé la veille de paris la directrice
de la fondation giacometti catherine
grenier voit pour la première fois les
oeuvres installées au musée national des
beaux-arts du québec visite en compagnie
de la directrice du musée line ouellet
une expo chronologique
né en 1901 giacometti et suisses
italiens il aura une phase
impressionniste dans les années 30
ensuite pendant la seconde guerre
giacometti créé notamment des sculptures
de petit format parfois carrément des
miniatures son arrêt volume et jack
médecine donnera après la guerre les
oeuvres qu'il en fait connaître
mondialement deux grands bronze est filé
comme l'homme qui marche créée en 1960
dont québec expose un des rares
exemplaires cet homme qui marche c'est
un homme qu'il a pu voir dans la rue
mais c'est aussi le souvenir des
figurines égyptienne et notamment de ce
fameux pas en avant que l'on voit sur
les reliefs égyptiens
bien que suisse c'est surtout à paris
qu'il a fait carrière montparnasse
toujours dans le même minuscule studio
giacometti passera près de 40 ans à
perdre et à façonner l'argile pour
produire ses célèbres statues la matière
giacometti l'a fait et là des faits
constamment le dernier bus que je suis
un homme de fer
je ne fais comme l'aimé et il est
tellement gros que j'ai l'impression que
c'est encore le double de d'épaisseur
donc il vaut bonne enlevé en avait
enlevé et alors là je sais pas du tout
l'un c'est là où je me perds le plus
c'est parce que c'est comme si la
matière même de mener une illusion
je connais tu y étais jamais content de
ce qu'il faisait c'est un éternel
insatisfait
c'est quelqu'un qui vous
l'échec toujours le sentiment de l'échec
et en même temps pour lui ce sentiment
de l'échec il le dit il est positif
c'est ce qu'il pose tous les jours à
aller à son atelier giacometti réalise
des bronzes qui valent de l'or à londres
une version de l'homme qui pointe aussi
vendu à 126 millions de dollars le plus
gros montant jamais atteint en un an
qu'en public pour une sculpture nous
pour 20 dollars on peut voir une autre
version de l'homme qui pointe au musée
de québec
la force de giacometti l'universalité de
la description de l'humain je crois que
cdf qui touche beaucoup
elle touche tout le monde de tous les
âges
faisons d expression dans le monde
entier et c'est schématisation de
l'homme touch dans le monde entier et
c'est ce caractère universel qui fait
que les offres sont chers giacometti
travailler avec très peu de modèles sa
femme annette beaucoup son frère diego
aussi il fallait qu'ils soient
strictement immobile il pouvait pas
s'arrêter pour paléo toilettes il peut
pas fumer une cigarette
donc c'était quand même et puis parler
par les bolides dur avec ses modèles
n'étaient pas contents lui jurer cassé
ils détruisaient tout et ils ont du
reste quand même parce que tu ne sais
pas voir que c'est du bon sens qu'ils
choisiront du rsa parce qu'ils savaient
ils ont compris très vite les uns comme
les autres que ça fait partie de la
dynamique
triste de l'artiste il y a aussi eu
caroline 40 ans plus jeune que lui
prostituée son modèle son amoureuse sa
maîtresse avec la corde les pousse à ned
sa femme connaissait son mari sa femme
connaissez j'ai comme et il vivait dans
un milieu qui était un milieu d'artistes
ou l'amour libre était quelque chose de
tout à fait accepté c'était grand ami de
sartre et beauvoir qui tous les deux
avaient des aventures chacun de leur
côté mais qui gardaient un couple très
uni c'est pareil le musée des beaux-arts
de montréal avait présenté une
rétrospective giacometti il ya 20 ans
mais celle de québec est plus importante
avec 110 culture 50 peinture plus de 70
dessins et documents pour vous c'est bon
qu'on se permet écoutez je pense que
pour tous les citoyens du québec et du
canada c'est un grand bonheur puisque on
a ici des pièces d'exception un bon coup
qui a un bon coup en gros ce sont des
projets qui valent au lieu de au delà
d'un million
on est toujours très rarement vous allez
voir des expositions de ce format là qui
vont être en bas d'un million $ ces
sociétés seront rentables pour vous vous
croyez le mourre interne ne s'appliquera
s'applique rarement dans les musées vous
l'avez compris je pense que si la
rentabilité c'est le bonheur des
citoyens
elle va être amplement rotak une version
de l'exposition giacometti vient d'être
présentée à la tate modern de londres
ensuite ce sera le guggenheim à new york
pour finir au guggenheim de bilbao
mais jusqu'au 13 mai c'est à québec que
ça se passe